[Musique]
mon cœur me dit que j'ai donné ce que
j'avais à donner à titre de porte-parole
de Québec solidaire
je suis prête à passer le bâton du
pèlerin ou de la pèlerine
à la relève
[Musique]
la cour porte-parole de Québec solidaire
depuis maintenant 6 ans annoncé la
semaine dernière qu'elle souhaitait
céder sa place à la relève dès l'automne
prochain politicienne atypique militante
de la première heure la députée de
Sainte-Marie Saint-Jacques veut se
consacrer à son travail d'élus défendre
les injustices dans son victimes ses
citoyens nous a donné rendez-vous au
parc La Fontaine devant le manoir la
fontaine qui est devenu symbole de la
résistance des locataires face aux
éditions
maintenant masser bonjour bonjour Daniel
on est dans votre circonscription
honnêtement depuis quelques jours
maintenant je l'ai annoncé au Québec en
entier
ça me soulagé parce que j'aime pas ça
savoir des choses puis pas mais
c'est surtout maintenant je pense qu'on
est rendu à l'autre étape et c'est de
dire aux femmes du Québec vous avez
envie de changer le monde ça tombe bien
il n'y a pas de porte-parole à Québec
soldat qui se libère ouvrez la porte
quelque part mais vous avez mais vous
l'avez aimé cette job là ça a été
compliqué dire ok je tourne la page oui
oui ça a été un long processus c'est
plusieurs mois que je suis là dedans
mais vous savez avoir un emploi à temps
plein comme porte-parole puis un emploi
en temps plein comme député amener ça
devient difficile puis moi décidé de
prendre les énergies qui me restent pour
les consacrer justement aux gens de ma
circonscription quand vous l'avez
annoncé cette semaine on vous sentait
très émotive quand vous parliez de vos
commettant de vos électeurs dans la
circonscription d'ailleurs vous nous
avez donné rendez-vous dans votre
circonscription et vous avez dit dans la
dans la conférence de presse il y a une
crise humanitaire chez nous qu'est-ce
que vous voulez dire bah écoutez tout le
monde qui côtoient le centre-ville de
Montréal le centre sud voit bien que la
réalité depuis la pandémie s'est
transformée les logements sont plus
accessibles financièrement les gens se
retrouvent à la rue il y a de le
centre-ville est identifié comme un lieu
pour l'immigration pour les réfugiés
donc les gens se retrouvent sans repères
en plein milieu du centre-ville
l'itinérance augmente les défis de santé
mental augmente il y a des années qui se
font émincer à 90 ans de l'horlogements
leur résid ence pour un nez bref c'est
beaucoup trop de drames humains pour un
si beau quartier et moi c'est ça c'est
là je sens que ces gens-là ont besoin
d'espoir ont besoin de sentir qu'il y a
vraiment quelqu'un qui qui marche à le
côté et c'est ça que je veux me
consacrer le l'énergie qui me reste j'en
ai encore c'est pas que j'en ai plus
mais c'est là que je veux la mettre je
vais me faire l'avocat du diable il y a
des gens qui diraient
club de comporte-parole ça a plus de
poids c'est votre message porte plus non
c'était pas une belle tribune pour vous
pour défendre ce genre de de ce genre de
causes là je pense que
avec les années où j'ai été confortable
j'ai fait la démonstration que
ce que je porte comme parole donc la
dépense de droit que je fais je le fais
avec tout ce que je suis et que je sois
qu'au porte-parole ou non je pense que
vous allez continuer à m'inviter dans
votre émission parce que c'est important
ce que j'ai à dire et j'ai des dossiers
et nationalement je continue à avoir des
dossiers l'itinérance les relations avec
les Premières nations les personnes qui
vivent avec une déficience
intellectuelle ou un trouble du spectre
de tisse donc les communautés LGBT aussi
moi je suis pas inquiète
c'est une question de mesure d'énergie
je vais avoir 60 ans dans quelques jours
et quand je mets ça dans
dans la balance j'ai fait ce choix là je
l'ai fait pour moi et je pense que c'est
en fait pas je pense c'est le bon choix
est devenu entre le moment où vous avez
pris la job de cours de parole celui où
vous quitter ce poste là comment Québec
Solidaire a changé
début 2017 c'est ça l'image si on est
trois députés
on essaie de de se faire entendre on
réussit pas toujours on fait plein de
points de presse où il y a pas un média
qui est là pour nous couvrir mais on
croit à notre affaire c'est sûr que six
ans plus tard on est rendu 12 députés
on fait plus jamais être moins de 13 où
il y a pas de média qui sont là
et on continue de jouer ce rôle majeur
parce qu'à l'Assemblée nationale il y a
un parti
qui défend la voix des gens qui en ont
pas
qui défend aussi la classe moyenne parce
que quand on parle de logement quand on
parle d'habitation on parle de gens qui
travaillent qui sont même pas capables
de se payer un logement
je vois juste un parti qui est en
développement en expansion c'est
d'ailleurs c'est ce qui me permet de
dire que je parle la tête tranquille il
y a de la relève elle est là mais aussi
le parti est en santé le véhicule est
solide qu'est-ce qui manque à Québec
solidaire d'après vous
c'est 18 ans là c'est mon bébé
je pense que la dernière élection
lorsque nos membres nous ont invités à
aller vers les régions à se mettre en
mode dialogue asseyez de comprendre
comment comment se fait que ça la
chimie passeport pas de connexion la
chimie et
en toute humilité on s'est dit parfait
on va aller sur le terrain
c'est trop urbain c'est urbain oui
l'habitude médicalement ça a pas été
trop longtemps
Sherbrooke aussi mais c'est une école
d'exception la majorité de vos députés
sont dans la région de Montréal
exactement mais ce que je voulais juste
vous signifier c'est que longtemps
durant les premières années on nous a
dit Québec soldat est un parti
montréalais et ça c'était comme là on
fait lire des gens à Québec à Sherbrooke
à
Rouyn-Noranda
oui oui mais ça c'est exceptions voilà
on construit c'est se construire
tranquillement puis honnêtement quand on
regarde nos résultats dispersés à
travers le Québec
quand on regarde ça on se dit ben non au
Québec solaire est partout maintenant ce
qu'il faut c'est faire mieux c'est pour
ça qu'on va aller se mettre en dialogue
en écoute avec les gens est-ce que la
prochaine comporte -parole devrait venir
des régions
prochaine comporte-parole pour moi ce
qui est important c'est que dans cette
course au porte-parola il y a eu il y
aura eu de l'espace pour que des femmes
fortes intelligentes peu importe leur
profil peu importe leur niveau de dans
le cadre où il fait pas que ces femmes
là vont venir débattre ensemble de leur
vision alors est-ce qu'elle viendra des
régions est-ce que le rôle la chance
d'être
moi je sais pas ce que je veux c'est le
débat d'idée alors j'espère que les
femmes vont démontrer qu'on est capable
de faire ça correctement merci